bonjour à tous on a beaucoup parlé de
samsung galaxy x galaxie disent je
suppose de gak 6 c'est effectivement un
smartphone dont on parle beaucoup depuis
2011 enfin smartphones il aurait dû
arriver qui n'est toujours pas là qui
arrivera bientôt
il arrivera c'est une certitude on ne
sait pas quand et là on a des nouvelles
infos vraiment intéressante pour savoir
à quoi il va ressembler comment est ce
qu'il va être conclu
on s'est beaucoup posé la question et
aujourd'hui je suis très content qu'on
puisse enfin il voit plus clair
on y va maintenant
le galaxy s c'est vraiment un produit
qui va changer la face du smartphones
des téléphones portables parce que
aujourd'hui vous êtes des smartphones
tous plus ou moins classique un peu
comme moi avec mon fils est un
smartphone un écran 1 donne appareil
photo voilà un truc comme ça ça se met
dans la poche qui sont plus ou moins
grand en sont les grands formats des
petits formats rebonds mais ils ont tous
un petit peu là même le même forme avec
un petit peu les mêmes finitions avec le
galaxy x ça va être vraiment autre chose
l'idée c'est effectivement d'avoir un
smartphone complètement pliable avec un
écran pliable et on s'est toujours posé
la question à savoir comment il allait
se plier et 6 plié est expliquée sur
l'intérieur par l'extérieur est ce qu'on
aura quand même un écran sur le dessus
pour voir un peu ce qui se passe parce
que pour voir un peu de notification nos
appels entrants voir un petit peu et
bien qu'ils cherchent à nous rejoindre
si c'est pas conçu comme ça à quoi ça va
ressembler comment expliquer l forme si
ça voilà c'est un peu très compliqué et
juste moche très content parce que il ya
des infos qui sont sorties qui ont un
petit peu futés qui nous définit un
petit peu le portrait robot de ce
produit on va effectivement avoir un
produit avec deux écrans par un seul et
même grand écran qui va se replier un
peu comme un bouquin et ce qui est cool
c'est qu'on va retrouver un écran sur le
dessus alors imaginons d écran de 3,5
pouces 3 5 pouces c'est pas grave du
tout vaudoise écran 3.5 pouces une fois
qu'on les ouvre on aura un écran de 7
pouces alors on sait que vous aurez
effectivement on a des écran de 6 pouces
voir un tout petit peu plus sur des
smartphones et là par contre ça
permettra effectivement d'avoir un vrai
gain de place dans votre poche et un peu
plus de confort de lecture et on
pourrait imaginer effectivement que tous
les éditeurs vont améliorer légèrement
moins du point de vue de l' os et
améliorer les applications pour vraiment
en tirer profit
donc ça va être vraiment très
intéressant donc un écran 7 pouces une
fois replié vous auriez votre écran en
façade
a priori également de 3,5 pouces avec
les informations importantes
c'est-à-dire vos notifications vos
appels votre votre agenda
et puis toutes les infos qu'on peut
retrouver qui sont vraiment importantes
sur un écran de veille plus dans cet
esprit là on serait sur des écrans oled
donc quelque chose avec du conte avec un
contraste infini des lumières vraiment
très intéressant des couleurs intenses
un produit avec une excellente qualité
qui pourrait arriver alors je garde
toujours des grandes guillemets avec ce
produit mais qui pourrait arriver on dit
on l'a attendu en 2018 je l'espérais
depuis la fin 2017
mais bon vous voyez tous les ans on en
parle on nous annonçait effectivement
2017 2018 il toujours pas là pour
l'instant à mon avis 2018 à être
compliqué de l'avoir parce que une fois
que le produit soit réellement terminée
ensuite il va y avoir toutes les phases
de fabrication de produits tout le
travail du marketing autour de salon
avant d'avis 2018 on peut l'oublier
il pourrait arriver en 2019 est-ce qu'il
serait présenté au cs au mwc est ce
qu'il serait présenté sur une pilote
spécial c'est un peu compliqué d'autant
plus que à priori ce produit serait
vraiment distribué en petits volumes dès
le départ pour prendre un pot de tester
le marché on parle effectivement de cinq
cent mille à 2 millions de produits
fabriqués au début ça peut paraître
énorme réalité c'est vraiment pas grand
chose l'idée si vous voulez c'est
d'aller tester le marché de voir un
petit peu la réaction du public est ce
que ce produit se citera un intérêt réel
au-delà de la rumeur parce que c'est
facile un peu d'abord un intérêt sur une
rumeur est toute une nouvelle génération
de produits
mais après est-ce que les consommateurs
vont venir l'acheter est ce qu'une fois
utilisé les gens vont trouver un intérêt
est ce que les développeurs
d'applications vont bosser dessus car il
ya beaucoup de questions qui restent en
suspens j'imagine que pour cent en
dessous en tout cas il y en a d'autres
qui se positionne dans la course
notamment apple ou away et compagnie
lenovo sur ses écrans pliables mais est
ce que pour samsung vu le travail on
recherche et développement depuis des
années est ce que ce produit fini de
cette manière dont on le décrit
aujourd'hui aura du succès oui ou non
c'est difficile à prédire donc j'imagine
que pour eux il marche un peu sur des
oeufs
parce qu'ils savent aujourd'hui que le
format qu'on ad'abord actuel fonctionne
effectivement ils vendent un peu moins
bien
le tout renouvellement des smartphones a
baissé et fort heureusement parce que on
va pas non plus sur consommer des
portables mais d'un autre côté pour eux
voilà il faut le tester il faut voir un
petit peu son public est réceptif
est-ce que ça les intéresse voilà pour
les infos qu'on a aujourd'hui pour citer
mac source ces infos nous viennent du
site the bell ça soulève beaucoup de
questions parce que il reste quand même
la question des appareils photos comment
vont intégrer les appareils photo on
imagine effectivement un écran enfin
grand écran de 7 pouces une fois replié
vous aurez votre écran à l'avant à
l'arrière qu'est ce qu'on aurait qu'est
ce qu'on aura est ce qu'on aura un des
appareils photo à ce moment là est ce
qu'on aura un appareil photo de cette
fille est ce qu'on aura un appareil
photo à l'intérieur parce qu'on va
beaucoup plus d'utiliser une fois ouvert
comme une petite fable est est ce que le
format pocket
être vraiment intéressant est ce que les
charnières on est résistante comment
est-ce qu'on va les stocker une batterie
dans tout ça et au final est ce qu'on
risque pas effectivement bien évidemment
de gagner en hauteur mais pas d'avoir un
produit très épais dans la poche
donc ça ça reste un petit peu le
challenge pour samsung ou sortir
vraiment un produit fini hyper sexy
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que vous ne
craignez pas un peu que le produit
malgré tout soit un petit peu épais même
si les écrans pliables ne sont pas du
tout et pc parce qu'il posera problème
mais malgré tout il faut loger de battre
et ailleurs est ce qu'on aura une
batterie ion elle oui ou non comment on
voit en effet ses appareils photos voilà
à toutes ces questions un peu de la
miniaturisation qui se posent sur ce
produit là donc dites moi ce que vous en
pensez
bien évidemment rassurez-vous ce un
produit mon avis il y aura pas du tout
ce temps jack parce qu'elle va vraiment
falloir à gagner sur l'épaisseur du
produit donc on va réduire tous qui
prend de la place
pour jack entre autres dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
ce que je vous ai décrit vous parle en
tout cas suffisamment intéressant j'ai
lu les commentaires sur notre vidéo où
on parlait d' écran pliable vous dites
mais effectivement quel est l'intérêt
d'avoir un produit pliable si ce n'est
juste pour avoir un nouveau truc tout
petit dans la poche mais ce que du point
de vue du consommateur il ya réellement
un intérêt ça effectivement c'est une
question hyper légitime je me la pose
également demandé sur le principe je
trouve que l'idée est géniale par contre
est-ce que c'est petit écran de 3,5
pouces pas vraiment être intéressant est
ce que partir c'est un truc de 7 pouces
alors qu'on va dès aujourd'hui des
smartphones avec des six pouces est-ce
qu'il va vraiment y avoir un intérêt ce
qu'il va falloir réfléchir encore
différent a priori microsoft travaille
sur son projet andromeda pour proposer
quelque chose de encore révolutionnaire
est ce que ça serait là dessus qu'on
dirait ressassent encore sur autre chose
est ce que parce que je sais par ya
encore plein de questions à se poser
donc c'est moi vous ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que ça vous
paraît cool intéressant oui non donc de
toute façon je vous invite à vous
abonner parce que on va beaucoup parler
moi je trouve ça un sujet passionnant
parce que ça permet un petit peu de voir
l'avenir de la téléphonie mobile
comment on va les utiliser tout tout
l'oeuf la façon dont nous on va aborder
ces nouveaux produits
donc je trouve ça vraiment génial mark
et moi tous vos commentaires comme
d'habitude vous invite à laisser des
jolies pousse à vous abonner pour suivre
un petit peu tout ça tu vois toutes les
nouveautés qui vont arriver dans les
mois à venir d'ici là un portez vous
bien soyez ça je vous embrasse pour lé
soin de vous
[Musique]